before we get going I wanted to mention
the Western conservative summit is June
8 next week
the Colorado Convention Center in Denver
I'm gonna be speaking on on June 8th and
so I hope to see you there it is the the
Western conservative summit is the
largest gathering of conservatives that
happens every year outside of DC which
is a big bonus because as someone who
goes to DC on a regular basis I can tell
you that if you could spend your whole
life and never enter that cursed City
you will be doing something right so it
should be a should be a good time and
hope to see you there let's talk about
free speech free speech is one of the
most overused misused misunderstood
phrases and concepts in American society
today everybody claims to be in favor of
free speech everyone tends to make
everything into a free speech issue
everyone is always saying that their own
free speech rights are being infringed
upon and while we are constantly talking
about free speech I think in the vast
majority of cases and with the vast
majority of controversies that we argue
about they really have nothing at all to
do with free speech I I think 95% of the
time probably that's a conservative
estimate when somebody says this is
about free speech it actually is not
about free speech at all it that's most
of the time I think this is particularly
relevant to discuss today the reason
it's on my mind today is because this
has been a a week which has featured a
blizzard of phony free speech claims
let's start with of course Roseanne we
don't have to go through that whole
thing again but she said what she said
about Valerie Jarrett she was fired of
course and Roseanne's supporters and
people who like the show many of them
said this is a free speech issue she
needs to be know she should still have
her show in the interests of free speech
but free speech had nothing to do with
it then we had Samantha be on the other
end of the spectrum she called Ivanka
Trump a feckless c-word and she said
some other result of revolting things
about Ivanka as well this is just
another in a long line of unfunny vile
things that this person has said on a
nightly basis and I was among those who
called for her to be fired and I was
told that I didn't value free speech and
I was in
the first amendment for taking that
position this is the way it goes
generally if you believe that a person
ought to suffer consequences for saying
gross and reprehensible things or if you
believe that gross and reprehensible
things ought not be set in the first
place even if you think that they should
be allowed to be said you don't think
that they should be said in any case
then you're going to be accused of
infringing on the First Amendment
there's a lot of confusion here clearly
and I think if we're gonna talk about
free speech we should probably begin by
trying to determine what exactly free
speech is you know what is free speech I
think it's kind of two ways of looking
at it there's the right way in the wrong
way so when you say free speech you
could be referring to that free speech
which is enshrined in the First
Amendment the legal free speech and this
give the First Amendment gives you the
right to express your views and beliefs
especially your political views and your
religious beliefs without being punished
by the government or without being
censored by the government it prohibits
the government from passing laws that
would require you to hold a certain view
or prohibit you from from holding
certain views that's what the First
Amendment is all about it's all about
the government it's got nothing to do
with how the culture reacts to speech
it's all about what the government does
and doesn't do and it's not absolute of
course there are restrictions it's it's
it's not it's not enough to say or it's
not accurate to say that free speech
means you could say whatever you want
the government can't stop you know you
can't say whatever you want you can't
slander you can't lie under oath you
can't intentionally incite violence
against another person you can't shout
fire in a crowded theater you can't do
those kinds of things so there are
restrictions on free speech and I think
most people agree that there ought to be
those restrictions so it's not absolute
but that's basically what free speech is
great then there's the second there's
the there's the incorrect
I think usage of this term free speech
and it's a little bit unclear to me
exactly what it means because it's it's
it's it's obvious that when most people
say free speech they're not referring to
the legal freeze
because like I said when they use the
phrase they're using it in a context
that has nothing to do with legal free
speech at all so obviously they mean
something else they're taught they're
not they're talking about a different
kind of free speech and it seems and
this is just me this is just me kind of
based on context it seems like most of
the time when this term free speech is
used what the person is referring to is
a kind of cultural free speech and what
they're saying is that the culture ought
to be welcoming of all speech and what
they're saying is that a person like
Roseanne or Samantha B shouldn't be
fired for saying reprehensible things
because we should be a society that
welcomes and tolerates
all speech even reprehensible speech and
we should never attempt to correct or
suppress or otherwise punish any speech
at all
they believe that legal free speech is
not enough so we have to have this
cultural free speech as well where we're
welcoming and tolerant of all speech now
I don't believe in that kind of free
speech I don't think that anyone really
believes in it to be honest with you I
think a lot of people claim to believe
in it but but but in reality even if you
say yeah people should be able to say
whatever they want we shouldn't we
shouldn't try to you know punish them
for it you may say that but I don't
think you really mean it because I think
you draw a line somewhere too maybe for
you Samantha me didn't cross that line
maybe Roseanne didn't cross that line
but there is a line almost definitely
there is a line there there is something
that a person can say especially in a
public position that would make you go
they need to be fired for that so I
think everyone has a line but we claim
not to because we all want to be so
open-minded and so or so open-minded I
don't claim to be open-minded
I'm not open-minded I I'm all about
figuring out what the truth is and once
I know the truth I'm sticking with that
I'm not you know I
I'm not even consider a falsehood I'm
just gonna stick with what the truth is
and I also believe that we all should
operate with some human decency and I'm
pretty narrow-minded about that I don't
think that no I think decency is the way
to go
so I'm not going to consider indecency I
think no decency that's the way I don't
believe that we as a society are obliged
to be welcoming and tolerant of all
speech I don't believe that a person
should be able to say the most vile and
disgusting reprehensible things and
suffer no penalty whatsoever for saying
them I don't believe that our founders
didn't believe that that's not what our
founders were talking about when they
talked about free speech this is a
concept of free speech that is rather
new and rather frankly ridiculous
because what we're doing is we're
drawing a line now between speech and
decency and what we're saying is that
you have to choose between being a
society with free speech or a society
with decency I don't agree with that I
think we can be both but it seems like a
lot of people think that any attempt by
individuals and the marketplace to
contain and control the filth and
stupidity that is spewed or any attempt
to free ourselves from having to be
exposed to the filth and stupidity every
second of every day is a violation of
free speech by this way of thinking I
strongly disagree with that way of
thinking here's how I think about it I
think you have the legal right to be a
profane babbling idiot you have the
legal right I have the right to treat
your profane babbling idiocy as profane
babbling idiocy I not only have the
right to do so I am right in doing so
that's how I should treat it that's how
society should treat it I think we
should strive to be a society where we
are all legally free to say what we want
within reason but we still would make
the effort to speak and behave with some
decorum because we know that we will
face shame and stigma from society if we
don't that's the kind of society we
should be that's the kind of society we
used to be in the 1950s a woman wasn't
going to get up there in public and call
somebody else
with c-word because she would have been
shamed for that that would've been too
much shame and stigma nobody would have
applauded nobody would have laughed
everybody would have said that's
disgusting you should be ashamed of
yourself should be ashamed what's wrong
with you that's how it would have been
treated that's how it should be treated
we should all be completely intolerant
of that kind of language and we should
be completely intolerant of certain
opinions and I know that opinion
opinions have become this sacred holy
thing where we say oh it's somebody's
opinion so we have to respect it I don't
care if it's your opinion if it's wrong
and stupid then I'm gonna treat it that
way I don't have to respect it just
because it's your opinion people like to
say well everyone is entitled to his own
opinion yeah that's true a guy's
entitled to his own opinion fine I mean
in the sense that he can he's allowed to
form opinions and nobody can stop him
but he's not entitled to have those
opinions taken seriously he's not
entitled for those opinions to be
welcomed or accepted and he's not
necessarily free or he ought not be free
necessarily from the consequences of
expressing those opinions a white
supremacist or a black supremacist or
any kind of racial supremacist because
they come in all colors by the way but a
a racial supremacist should experience
social consequences for those views
because they are deranged and evil and
idiotic and they're also dangerous if
enough people adopt them we've seen what
happens when a majority of a population
become racial supremacist it has led to
some of the worst bloodshed and
persecution in the history of mankind so
yeah we should as a society militate
against those opinions because they're
so awful and there's nothing redeeming
about them at all they don't deserve to
be taken seriously should the government
prevent racial supremacist from from
gathering together and saying their
stupid opinions
but should society shun that speech and
mock it and treat it with contempt yes
absolutely again just because you say
something doesn't automatically make it
legitimate just because it's your belief
or your opinion doesn't mean it's not
repugnant and foolish and thus deserving
of ridicule we've developed this really
childish idea that like I said that that
all opinions are valuable all opinions
about we should listen to all opinions
though we shouldn't there are a lot of
really opinions that are utterly
worthless should be treated that way
well that's my opinion
so what does that mean that's like if
you if you took a big steaming pile of
dung right in you and you took it in you
and you put it on a plate and you served
it to somebody and you said here it's
food and then the person said I don't
want to eat that
and you said but it's food it's my food
that I'm giving you
yeah but it's still a steaming pile of
dung isn't it the fact that it's food
and that it's you who's serving it to me
that doesn't mean anything in fact it
just makes me think of less of you that
you're giving me this that's all it does
it doesn't make the steaming pile of
dung less less of it less disgusting
this is you this is why I think there is
I'm trying to think of the make sure I'm
putting this the right way because I
know it's we tend to think of free
speech in America as the the most holy
and sacred thing but it's not really the
most holy and sacred and precious thing
is the truth that's what really matters
the truth and so I think we should be a
little bit less focused on free speech
and we should be a little bit more
focused on on what is right on the truth
so we should spend less time clamoring
about what our rights are and more time
talking about what is right
society should give legal rights to
everyone but it should only embrace and
accept that which is right and decent so
let you know this is a point that I've
made about the situation on college
campuses I think that the conservative
critique of the environment on college
campuses is a bit misdirected and it
kind of misses the point because if you
were to ask the average conservative
what's the biggest problem on modern
college campuses on most college
campuses liberal college campuses
especially which is most of them I think
the average conservative what are they
going to say they're gonna say that the
big problem is that these campuses are
so intolerant of and hostile to opposing
ideas no that's not the problem
actually the problem is that colleges
today are so hostile to an intolerant of
the right ideas that's the problem it's
that they're hostile to the truth my
point is there's nothing wrong with
being hostile to an idea because some
ideas deserve hostility the idea that
it's okay to kill babies in the womb is
a stupid insane evil irrational idiotic
view that is that deserve to be treated
with contempt and hatred the view itself
should be treated with contempt and
hatred and ridicule that's how awful and
dumb it is just because it's an opposing
idea from my own doesn't mean I
expected no you think it's okay to kill
babies I don't respect that what's wrong
with you are you crazy no it's not okay
to kill babies it's just the same thing
if you came up to me and you said you
know what I really think maybe it's okay
to enslave black people I'm not gonna
sit here and say okay well let's sit
down and have a conversation I'm gonna
say that's insane what's wrong with you
of course it's not okay get out of here
I'm not even gonna listen to that you're
there but no hear me out now I'm not
gonna listen I'm not gonna hear you out
because I'm not an idiot and I know that
that's wrong of course it's wrong
there's nothing interesting or redeeming
you can say in favor of it so no it is
okay sometimes to treat ideas with
hostility
that that's a sign of societal health if
we're treating if we are directing that
hostility and that contempt in the right
direction
the problem is our society miss directs
it and which we often treat the truth
and the right ideas with contempt that's
the problem
so conservatives they need to stop
whining and saying well no listen to my
ideas because there are the opposing
ideas and they deserve to be respected
stop that
stop being weak no stand up and say
listen to my ideas because my ideas are
right that's why they deserve to be
listened to
because they're true and they're right
and you're wrong that's why you should
listen to me it's not just because it's
the opposing idea I'm not gonna put my
ideas in a hole in a big basket called
ideas and and lump it in with all other
ideas no this is the right idea the
right the idea that you shouldn't kill
babies is right and that's why you
should listen to it that's why my idea
deserves more respect than yours because
you think we should kill babies and
that's wrong and stupid and insane there
is there are a few it's rare that you
encounter it but there are there are
some college campuses out there mostly
small conservative Christian schools
where
if you went there and tried to argue for
killing babies you would just be laughed
out of the room because everybody
because you know what because the people
on campus are morally and intellectually
farmed and so they have no interest in
that idiocy you see and that's good
because what's the real what's the real
goal of Education it's not just it's not
to make open-minded people who are who
listen to opposing ideas no it's to make
people who understand and are grounded
in the truth that's what that is the
only thing that matters in life it's the
whole point of existence is truth it's
the only thing that matters that's what
education is for and the problem with
education is that we are creating people
who are hostile to truth if we were to
take that hostility or if they were to
take it and direct it to falsehood and
evil and depravity then that would be
good that's an improvement that's growth
that's what we want all right you get my
point hopefully this is just it's it's
become a it's become a special pet peeve
of mine all these people who people who
have the truth on their side yet they
demand to be listened to on the basis of
free speech and open dialog like what's
wrong with you you have the truth why
not bring that's the point
so in conclusion legal free speech is
great and we should absolutely fight for
it and in the cases where it is
threatened let's take the case that's
gonna be the verdict will be declared by
the the Supreme Court in the next week
or two
masterpiece cake shop and their fight
against the LGBT mob now that is a real
honest-to-god free speech issue and if
masterpiece cakes
Liuzza's then that's essentially the end
of the first amendment so that's a big
deal and so we got to pay attention to
that
so we're legal free speech is actually
threatened we need to defend it but
outside of that you're under no
obligation to tolerate or take seriously
falsehood indecency vulgarity profanity
except etc and you shouldn't and society
shouldn't and that's the society that we
should build thanks for listening
everybody I'll talk to you next week
Godspeed